so this one time we're playing Minecraft
you have the one for the PlayStation
shadow of the classes the Kingdom Hearts
series Mass Effect the download content
for BioShock Infinite half-life 2 final
fantasy 7 was the most influential video
game of my entire life I'm like 14 years
old and binging for about 30 hours
playing this game I went through it
finished it without sleeping got done at
10:00 a.m. it's a pretty spooky game we
love scary games though for the butcher
in that game it's when the main girl was
getting tortured halfway through files
to 6 all your friends get lost and the
camera cuts to that shot above like kind
of above looking down at this field of
flowers and these two characters
standing there and it just stays there
and nothing really happens and you're
kind of waiting for him to do it and
then the button prompt pops up in the
corner of the screen that little r1 pops
up that like tells you it's he's not
going to do it until you pull the
trigger
I had a panic attack during that scene
because it scared me so much that I
dropped the controller and I had to turn
the TV off you screamed it was like a
shriek like I was just blown away by it
it was just a really powerful moment and
from then on like that that was the
moment that kind of like just lit the
spark of Oh games can do something
really unique here something that no no
other medium can emulate this than a way
that I can think of and by the end of it
I'm just following my eyes out and I
just found him up with everything about
it I'd like this to go on the record
that I did not remember he totally did
scream no didn't scream it was funny it
was awesome and my grandfather who was
an engineer right afterwards told me
that uh you know you make those games
through programming which he'd very
briefly shown me before that and I was
so amazed by that idea that I decided
that's what I wanted to do with my life
and here we are like over 20 years later
and I've been in the game industry for
10 years which has where all my
friendships are my career even my
husband met my wife met my best friends
in the entire world me and my friend
best friend at the time played it and uh
one of the big major things of the story
is like friendship being like a power
like an internal power and stuff like
that and since we had been friends for
so long and playing that game together
it just it really stuck with both of us
and I don't know it's like how do I say
this I don't know like when I saw his
quotes is my friends are my power and so
I guess anyway that's mine too any game
that really does that kind of thing to
you can make you may you know make you
have you know big macho tears it's
exactly what you're looking for
and that's my little story
Oh